n
efficace, et les usagers
viendront.
d du fleuve...
Une place du village...
Comme un petit monde à part...
- Pourtant, t'sais, on n'est pas
sur une autre planète, là,
on est à Montréal!l!l!
- Cette réflexion ne lui vient
pas en tête pour la quiétude des
lieux, mais pour ses difficultés
de recrutement.
JONATHANcteur,
corporation commun. de la Pointe
- Ils envoient leur CV,
on les convoque en entrevue,
puis là, ils nous rappellent,
ils nous disent : "Oh, bien,
j'ai pas de voiture. Je vais pas
là, je vais pas à Pointe-aux-
Trembles. C'est bien trop loin,
t'sais!"
- Tout l- Tout l- Tout le monden
ici. Le REM faciliterait la vie.
- Les centres commerciaux,
comme la place Versailles,
les galeries d'Anjou,
ès long.
- Ils veulent se trouver
une job dans le centre-ville.
Ils pourraient.
Ils pourraient très bien.
- Mais pant, on tente
encore de recoller les morceaux
politiques entre Québec
et Montréal.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québecu Quéc
- On va faire une belle annonce
d'un beau projet ajusté.
DOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe
de l'opposition officielle
- La mairesse est tellement
de bonne humeur et apprécie
tellement le projet qu'elle
a dit qu'elle se sentait acculée
au pied du mur.
- Ce que la mairesse trouve,
c'est que certains dirigeants
de la Caisse sont un peu durs
dans les négociations.
- Est-ce que, minimalement,
la Ville de Montréal pourraitêté
décisionnel?
- Valérie Plante a donné
un exemple pour appuyer
cette demande.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- Il y a deux semaines,
on a appris que le tracé
sur Sherbrooke était maintenant
sur Souligny. Bien,
on l'a appris la veille.
- Quant à la ministre
chargée du dossier...
CHANTAL ROULEAU, ministre
déléguée aux Transports
- Je vais vous présenter
une nouvelle carte.
- ... qui montre que l'est
sera enfin relié au grand réseau
métropolitain.
Et dans son épicerie fine,
cette commerçante y croit.
JOHANNE PAIEMENT, prés. Asso.
des commerçantes, P.-A.-T.
- Moi, je suis partisane de ce
qu'on appelle l'ensemencement,
là, qui est "let's build it
and they'll come".
C'est comme ça que je vois ça.
Plus on va être intéressants,
plus on aura des gens intéressés
à nous connaître.
- Métro de Laval : le plus bel
exemple. "Oh, on projette
12 000, 8000 utilisateurs
par jour". Première journée :
40 000, puis ça a jamais baissé.
JEAN-DENIS CHAREST, président
Chambre de commerce, est de Mtl
- C'est le transport, le mode de
transport qui va nous permettre
de transformer le territoire,
d'attire